commercial real estate on one side
residential real estate on the other
residential real estate interest rates
are high so that if your mom and dad are
going to move to Florida and get a
little house down there they're probably
not going to sell the house in Bedford
up in the Northeast why they could
Airbnb it or they could lease it out and
they've got a three percent mortgage and
the mortgage isn't that big so why not
keep it prices are coming down a little
bit but they're not crashing well the
reason this is the supply is low is
because your mom and dad and millions of
people like them don't want to sell
their house so there's no Supply if
there's no Supply prices stay high the
other side of it is the demand there's
not a lot of people wanting to buy a
house at a seven percent mortgage right
now so you've got buyers don't want to
buy at the high and they don't want the
price associated with the seven percent
mortgage